إيريس نعم، كيف حالك
والدة زوجتي وأختها وخالتي، لقد أصيبوا بمرض
الزهايمر، لقد أخافها حتى
الموت، وكانوا يتقدمون ببطء شديد
[موسيقى]
ربما قبل أربع سنوات، كانت تبكي لمدة
نصف ساعة
كل صباح مثل الساعة، وهذا
بكاء مليء بالبكاء  هل جربوا
أدوية مختلفة؟ كان
لديها ما يكفي من مضادات الاكتئاب للحفاظ على
هدوء الفيل
[موسيقى]
وما زالت تبكي
في عام 2019 بدأوا برنامجًا تجريبيًا
هنا في Morse life، إنه مجتمع يعيش فيه كبار السن
في فلوريدا، مرحبًا إيريس إيريس تم
إعطاؤها الحشيش، كما ترى  جميلة جدًا
اليوم، تدير الدكتورة ميلاني بون البرنامج الذي نقوم به في اتفاقية التنوع
البيولوجي، وكلها مختلفة،
وجاءت الكرات الواحدة والثانية والثالثة من الدكتورة وأعطتها
توقفًا عن البكاء مرة واحدة، ها نحن ذا يا عزيزتي،
يستغرق الأمر واحدة في الصباح وواحدة في الليل، انتهى
هذا يبدو  سحر استثنائي
[موسيقى] لقد
كان الأمر مثيرًا للإعجاب للغاية كيف كان الأمر
يشبه ما حدث مع شارلوت فيجي
حيث ترى النوبات تتغير
وتذهب يا إلهي، من
الجدير أن نتذكر أن هذه
النوبات السلوكية لدى المرضى المصابين
بالخرف يمكن أن تكون من أصعب النوبات التي
يصعب التحكم فيها  المثير للاهتمام
هو أن الباحثين اعتقدوا أنهم
رأوا هذه الفوائد لدى الأطفال الذين يعانون من
النوبات واعتقدوا أن هذه الفوائد نفسها
يمكن أن تنطبق بالفعل على المرضى الأكبر سنًا المصابين
بالخرف والذين
يعانون أيضًا من نوبات، وحتى الآن
ما وجده الباحثون هو أنه في
بعض الحالات  في بعض الحالات، نجح الأمر بشكل جيد حقًا
كما
رأيت للتو أنه لن ينجح مع
الجميع وهناك مخاوف حيث
رأيت زيادة في تعاطي القنب
بين كبار السن وشهدت أيضًا
زيادة في زيارات الطوارئ المتعلقة بـ
استخدام القنب، لذا فهو ليس علاجًا سحريًا،
بل يجب أن يكون شيئًا يتم التحكم فيه بعناية، ولكن مرة أخرى بالنسبة لبعض هؤلاء
المرضى الذين واجهوا تحديات حقيقية في
إدارة السلوك، وخاصة المرتبط
بالخرف، لا يبدو أنه
يعمل فحسب، بل بالنسبة لبعض هؤلاء المرضى هو الحل
الوحيد.  الشيء الذي يعمل
الأجنبية الأجنبية